if you're a DC fan chances are you're  looking forward to suicide squads  release this summer apparently the  executives at Warner Brothers are  excited too according to a report from  the rap a Suicide Squad sequel is  already in the works no joke variety  writer Justin crawl sent out some tweets  that corroborate the report the only  issue seems to be director david ayers  schedule the writer and director will be  busy working on the feature film bright  with screenwriter max landis so it seems  someone else will have to take over  writing duties for a second Suicide  Squad film Suicide Squad hits us  theaters on August fifth then we'll  finally get to check out Will Smith's  Deadshot Marco Roby's Harley Quinn and  Jared Leto's Joker if you want to stay  up to date on all the DC film news  you're already in the right place